قالت مصادر ليبيه للجزيره ان مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز
شده داخل لقائه رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عبد الحميد بايبا في طرابلس
الخميس الماضي شدد على ان المرحله التي
تعيشها ليبيا يجب ان تكون انتقاليه
ونهائيه بعيده عن اي مسارات سياسيه موازيه
واكد مدير على ضروره ان تؤدي الانتخابات
الى احداث استقرار في ليبيا واصفا حكومه
البيبه بشريك الذي يمكن الاعتماد عليه
وقالت المصادر الليبيه
تدعم الموقف الامريكي الرافضه لاي تدخلات
اجنبيه بما فيها وجود مرتزقه الروسيه في
ليبيا
واضافت المصادر
خلال لقائه مع اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
في بنغازي من المساسي بموانئ النفط
وحقولها واقل النواشنطن تريد استقرار قطع
النفط الليبي وعدم وقف تصديره كما حدث في
مره سابق
على صعيد اخر اجتمع اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه
المشتركه خمسه زائد خمسه الممثلون عن شرق
ليبيا وغربها بمقر اللجنه في سيرت وسط
البلاد لمناقشه اليات خروج القوات
الاجنبيه والمرتزقه من ليبيا وقال مصدر من
اللجنه للجزيره من الاجتماع الذي يستمر
يومين يبحث كذلك توحيد الادارات العسكريه
بين شرق البلاد الغربيه
اطلاق النار وذكر المصدر ان اللجنه ستحسم
مساله تشكيل قوه المشتركه من حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه وقوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
لتامين مناطق التماس بين الطرفين
معنى من طرابلس مراسل الجزيره احمد خليفه
اذا احمد نقتطاني رئيسيتان
في في ليبيا اليوم نتائج زياره ويليام
برانس واجتماع اللجنه
العسكريه بين شرق وغرب ليبيا
لنبدا بالاحدث حسن وهو اجتماع اللجنه
العسكريه 5+5 هذه اللجنه هي النتائج
لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الذي وقع بين قوات
بركان الغضب وقوات اللواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر في الثالث والعشرين من اكتوبر عام
2020 في جنيه باشراف امامي يمكن القول
عموما انه لا جديد في عمل لجنه خمسه زائد
خمسه منذ ذلك الوقت وهي تعقد الاجتماعات
فقط تتحدث مجرد مباحثات ومجرد حديث انها
تريد اخراج القوات الاجنبيه والمرتزقه
وتوليد كثير دوريات مشتركه هذا ما يقال في
كل اجتماع تقريبا لكن على الارض لا يوجد
شيء حتى الان فقط ما افلح فيها هذه اللجنه
المشتركه هو فتح الطرقات والمعابر والسبل
بين شرق البلاد وغربها بعد ان كانت مغلقه
في وقت ااه سابق اما اليوم فلا جديد ذكر
في اجتماع هذه اللجنه حتى الان الوضع على
ما هو عليه المرتزقه بقون والقوات
الاجنبيه ايضا باقيه والمؤسسه العسكريه ما
زالت مفككه لم تتوحد حتى الان ولعل السبب
في ذلك هو او حجر العثر هو اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر الذي يسر على استمرار
كونه قائدا عاما للجيش وهو ما يرفضه الجيش
الليبي الموجود في منطقه غرب البلاد هذا
ما يتعلق باجتماع اللجنه العسكريه خمسه
زائد خمسه ما يتعلق باجتماع بيرنس مصادرنا
اكلت لنا اليوم او حدثتنا عن نتائج
الاجتماعات التي عقدها بيرنز في طرابلس
هنا وايضا في الرجمه حيث مقر اللواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر بشكل عام الرجل يتحدث
عن ضروره اجراء الانتخابات وان تؤدي هذه
الانتخابات الى حاله الاستقرار العام في
البلاد وايضا طلب من حفظ ان همم ان يعترف
بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه وان يكون له تواصل
مع حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
وان الولايات المتحده لا تريد المزيد من
الانقسام في ليبيا وتريد وحده المؤسسات
المؤسسات الحكوميه والمؤسسات التنفيذيه
ولذلك لابد من التواصل بين الطرفين وايضا
كثير قوات مشتركه لتامين منابع النفط
وايضا منابع المياه
ومواني النفط وحقول النفط وان هذه المرحله
التي تعيشها ليبيا يجب ان تكون مرحله
انتقاليه نهائيا تنتقل فيها البلاد الى
المرحله الدائمه عبر اجراب الانتخابات
ايضا خلال لقائه مع حفتر حذر بيزنس حضر
حفتر من مساله همم اعاده اغلاق موانئ
النفط وحقول النفط مره اخرى وقال له ان
الولايات المتحده ترف هذه الخطوه وتطمح
باستمرار الى استمرار همم تدفق النفط
واستقرار قطاع النفط دون المزيد من
الاغلاقات التي تعطل انتاج النفط في ليبيا
ايضا في المقابل تحدث بابنيس مع بيبه
ووصفه بانه شريف مهم للولايات المتحده في
المقابل ايضا الدبيبه تحدث عن العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده وطالب بان تكون هناك
شراكه حقيقيه مبنيه على اسس امنيه
واقتصاديه وسياسيه بين الولايات المتحده
وبين الحكومته شكرا لك احمد خليفه مراسلنا
الجزيره من ترابلس